[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue pour une émission 100% qu'ovide
oui je sais c'est pas la première fois
qu'on parle de ce thème mais nous avons
vraiment des choses nouvelles et fortes
à vous dire avec nos deux invités qui
sont tous les deux médecins bonsoir le
rang lexandre voir votre médecin
chirurgien pour être plus précis mais
vous êtes aussi entrepreneur essayiste
votre dernier livre jouissez jeunesse a
été publié chez lattès et puis savons
aussi le plaisir d'accueillir comme
souvent le lundi patrick peloux bonsoir
d'acteurs vous êtes médecin urgentiste à
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
vous êtes président de l'association des
médecins urgentistes de france est votre
dernier livre urgence de vivre qui est
là qu est ce qu on dit ça vous avez ici
heureusement c'est pas grave on va la
refaire mais non parce qu'on est en
direct un recueil de vos chroniques à
charlie hebdo urgence de vivre donc aux
éditions du cherche-midi merci d'être là
pour pallier une fois de plus à mes
lacunes
on va commencer par parler de cette
campagne de vaccination qui est tout
sauf un long fleuve tranquille
il ya eu plusieurs rebondissements on va
s'arrêter les uns après les autres sur
les nouvelles informations que nous
avons eues d'abord cette note de la
direction générale de la santé qui
explique que pour la semaine du 8 mars
celle qui commence aujourd'hui puisque
nous sommes lundi
eh bien il n'y aura pas de vaccins pour
les médecins de vaccins astrazeneca
parce que il n'y a pas suffisamment de
commandes pour tout le monde et que donc
ce sont les pharmaciens qui vont être
prioritaire la djs ajoute que la semaine
prochaine ça ira mieux et que donc dans
huit jours les médecins pourront à
nouveau être approvisionnés sauf que
vous le savez les médecins ça fait deux
semaines maintenant qu'ils ont le droit
de vacciner
il aurait déjà injecté 200 mais des
vaccins à 200000 personnes résultat le
syndicat mg france demande aujourd'hui
la démission de jérôme salomon le patron
de la direction générale de la santé
patrick pelloux vous vous comprenez vous
la comprenez cette décision s'il n'y a
pas assez de vaccins bon on donne en
priorité aux pharmaciens s'est pas
illogique non alors au delà si c'était
juste une question de logique
s'en sortirait bien nous sommes à mon
sens en fait on est vraiment dans la
définition du scandale d'état
c'est à dire que pas de l'état en terme
de personne du chef de l'état ou du
premier ministre mais en scandale d'état
en terme de société en termes de de
fonctionnement de l'état c'est
dramatique c'est dramatique ce que
conteste mg france je les comprends tout
à fait ce week-end vendredi ça a été le
branle bas de combat parce que on ouvre
les frigos il y avait des vaccins
partout mais partout mais pas en fait
partout il y en avait pour les communes
y en avait pour les pompiers et dans les
hôpitaux sa arrivaient au compte gouttes
ce qui fait que le vaccin fighter qui
est important n'est toujours pas arrivée
n'arrivait pas en nombre dans les
hôpitaux ce qui fait que moi j'ai voulu
vacciner des patients qui avaient déjà
été vaccinées par le finder et on m'a
expliqué qu'ils avaient pas les deux
donc c'est dramatique
non d'autre part vous avez un jeu je
vais essayer de faire court parce que
voilà vous avez un jeu qui est
absolument insensé où vous avez ordres
et contre ordres alors on vaccine les
moins de 50 ans pile et plus puis
maintenant tout le monde qui finalement
non on revient les comorbidités ah oui
c'est les obèses non c'est plus les
obèses c'est l'hyper tension non non
c'est pas d'hypertension
non c'est les cancers a alors les
cancers mais dès qu'elle sushi mis au
pas sous chimio on n'y comprend plus
rien je leur en veux pas je jette pas la
pierre parce que je pense que c'est
quand même très compliqué à gérer mais
un merdier pareil faut quand même le
faire
on est en dessous et j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour nos amis marocains ils ont
rattrapé leur retard ils ont vacciné 10
% de leur population
nous on est toujours à -2 6% on ne s'en
sort pas ça reprend ce que disait le
président de la république quand il a
dit on était dans une promenade de
famille non c'est même pas on n'a même
pas commencé la promenade de famille
après le repas du dimanche midi
on est encore à table là c'est un chaos
total
quand vous êtes médecin et que je peux
vous lire les sms
ça fait deux jours que je propose mes
services pour aller vacciner on me
renvoie toujours pas un
1 un endroit quelque chose pour aller
vacciner
je suis donc inutile sans doute mais
c'est contradictoire avec cette
mobilisation générale et je comprends
tout à fait le premier ministre quand il
a fait vendredi
on vaccine il faut y aller il va dans
des centres de vaccination etc
c'est toujours très propre très bien en
règle générale ça marche pas je reçois
sur instagram des dizaines et des
dizaines de messages de gens qui disent
on m'a annuler mon rendez vous le centre
est fermé on a voulu y aller c'est plein
là c'est très drôle à l'hôtel dieu de
paris
comme ils ont très peur maintenant des
gens qui viennent se vacciner nous avons
cinq vigiles cinq vigiles pour laurent
tu es venu tu es d'accord
maintenant on sait plus donc il ya
bientôt tu as plus on est dans la
culpabilité plus on met des vigiles j'ai
vu reconduire des personnes âgées qui
venaient en disant excusez moi je ne
sais pas me servir d'internet le
téléphone que vous avez me répond pas
donc je suis venu au cas où anne on vous
vaccinera pas c'est c'est vraiment
écouté je pourrais vous en faire encore
une demi heure je préfère me taire
tellement je trouve ça mais mais mais
ridicule et scandaleux quoi mais qu'est
ce qui se passe laurent alexandre parce
que la mobilisation de l'état
elle est présente les vaccins on nous a
dit qu'ils arrivaient alors qu'est ce
que c'est que ce désordre dans les
vaccins ils n'arrivent pas encore
beaucoup non et effectivement on des
cours l'extrême complexité l'empilement
administrative du système de santé
français
on a créé un monstre bureaucratique et
le résultat c'est le waterloo vaccinale
actuelle comme le disait patrick le roi
du maroc mohamed 6 vaccine deux fois
plus vite que macron un pays sous
développé un pays émergent comme le
maroc vaccine deux fois plus vite que la
france on croit rêver
si on nous avait dit à cinq ans que le
maroc allait vacciner pour une maladie
un jour deux fois plus vite que la
france on l'aurait pas cru et c'est
pourtant la réalité
donc je crois que là on va pas à chaud
offert un psychodrame
il faut essayer de sortir du waterloo
vaccinale on
un taux de vaccination qui est
extrêmement faible ce qui va imposer des
mesures les 'bears' est liberticide
pendant encore plusieurs mois
mais après cette crise il va falloir
réfléchir à la réorganisation du système
de santé parce que c'est le test de
rorschach de notre système de santé il
ça révèle notre incapacité à faire ce qu
un pays du tiers-monde comme le maroc
est capable de faire qu'est ce que c'est
le test de rorschach
c'est quand on vous montre des tâches la
direction de la tâche mais et qu'on doit
déterminer le sens avec cette équipe six
qu'analyste pour revenir sur ce que dit
alexandre qui est très juste c'est que
vous avez des strates qui se tirent la
bourre là vous avez lu une indication de
la direction générale de la santé
bon vous avez sans doute une injonction
différente du directeur de la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie
c'est sans doute contradictoire avec le
comité vaccinale du professeur fisher
qui a jamais géré un problème de santé
publique mais on l'a mis là on aurait dû
mettre un militaire mais on l'a mis là
c'est contradictoire avec santé publique
france qui est contradictoire avec la
direction de l'organisation des hôpitaux
qui est contradictoire avec les agences
régionales de santé qui est
contradictoire avec les directeurs
d'hôpitaux qui sont contradictoires
même pas de la convention citoyenne
c'est 25 citoyens tirés au ces voiliers
et quelque part alors c'est très bien on
voulait la régionalisation alors là pour
le coup t'as pas un département qui
fonctionne comme un autre alors et la
somme homme comme on sait plus comment
faire on a dit aux pompiers vacciner
donc maintenant les pharmaciens vacciner
mais à la limite on se dit d'accord tout
le monde vaque sinon mais après on est à
nouveau dans le panneau parce que y'a
soi-disant plus de vaccins
les vaccins arrivent plus on sait plus
où ils sont et après vous avez des
cerbères qui d'un coup sont devant les
frigos pleins et 10 on peut pas vaccinés
on n'a pas assez de vaccins
c'est pour ça que le président de la
république au conseil de défense il a
dit je ne retournerai pas tant que les
frigos sont pleins
parce que vous avez cette ambiguïté je
vous le dis qu'il ya un certain nombre
de médecins qui dit je préfère garder
mes vaccins au kazoo au kazoo de quoi
et du coup le problème il est que là
vous avez l'épidémie alors pour le coup
qui est en train de remonter notamment
sur paris on a une saturation des lits
de réanimation donc ça recommence on va
être on va avoir l'air mais on va avoir
les stupides
si on a une troisième vague alors que
les autres pays qui ont vacciné ne leur
ont pas on a mais je vous assure fait
face et c'est insensé
alors je vais peut-être encore noircir
le tableau mais c'est une information
donc on vous la donne
on a découvert que dans les petites
fioles de vaccins pfizer but était qu'il
n'y avait pas si dose contrairement à ce
que l'on pensait mais que avec les
bonnes seringue
on pouvait en avoir sept a priori ça
ressemblait à une bonne nouvelle sauf
que l'administration ne l'entendait pas
de cette oreille
écoutez ce coup de gueule de jean paul
hamon c'est le président de la
fédération des médecins de france
quelqu'un a prévenu la rs qu'on était
capable de faire ces deux malheureux dit
touchez pas on a on a le on a le
protocole on a l'autorisation pour s'il
ose ne fait pas la septième est une
blague non mais c'est pas une blague
je viens de recevoir aussi un sms d'une
personne d'un médecin qui va se repérer
d'une hépatique tommy parce qu'elle a un
cancer et c est qu elle cherche
désespérément une dose of fighters là je
dois vous dire mais moi j'ai dit j'ai
vraiment des envies de dalé dézinguer le
ministère quoi qui sait ces gens
incapables de 2,2 de s'adapter
incapables de prendre des décisions
responsables en même temps laurent
alexandre la rs et de l'autorité
régionale de santé
elle doit respecter les contrats qui
sont faits avec les fabricants et donc
files heures a dit non pas je vous vois
un nombre de bouteilles mais un nombre
de doses qu'il faut pas dépasser
enfin chacun est dans son couloir et on
a l'impression que tout ça n'est pas
n'est pas cohérent et qu'on a un peu
oublié le patient dans cette histoire on
peut constater une seule chose il ya des
pays qui ont massivement vacciner
comme israël et l'angleterre qui
vaccinent très vite comme le maroc
on pourrait multiplier les exemples le
chili vaccine cinq fois plus vite que la
france est la france ne vaccinent pas
donc il ya un vrai problème
soit on est en déni de ce waterloo soit
on le regarde en face on le corrige
or au bout de deux mois et demi de
campagne vaccinale les ratés du début de
la campagne n'ont toujours pas été
corrigé donc là il ya un vrai vrai
problème sur la sueur administration la
france est le pays au monde où il y a le
plus les plus fortes dépenses publiques
la france est le pays au monde où il y a
les plus forts impôts et on n'est pas
foutu de vacciner la population alors
que le maroc qui arrive
il ya un vrai problème politique
derrière le waterloo vaccinale actuelle
je vous donne les réactions de nos
internautes qui sont aussi sévère que
vous dont vous a posé la question sur
twitter la stratégie de vaccination du
gouvernement est elle efficace
vous répondez non à 73% vous dirais que
c'est moi sur ce plateau où il ya plus
de 100% des invités juste à une réaction
de vie qui sur twitter qui nous dit pas
encore faudrait-il qu'il y ait une
stratégie
et puis ces réactions que je vous livre
celle de jeu petit 74 que s'est il passé
pour que notre système de santé
deviennent si mauvais alors que nous
étions les malheurs les meilleurs disait
ton nadia sur youtube je n'ai jamais vu
autant d'amateurisme et d'incompétence
il n'y a aucune organisation ni
concertation avec les différents
intervenants les bonnes décisions
tardent l'incertitude règne en maître et
puis encore une réaction celle d'anna
toujours sur youtube vous pouvez nous
suivre en direct on a fait appel à un
cabinet de conseil américain pour gérer
la logistique trois petits points c'est
lamentable
ils ont tout à fait raison le 5 août ça
coûte des millions ce cabinet de
consulting américain
ça pose un problème de souveraineté mais
ça c'est un autre dossier c'est pour ça
que moi mon avis on va on va dégainer
évidemment là il faudra une enquête
parlementaire pour comprendre et
simplifier le système de santé et avoir
des responsables et surtout un esprit de
contradiction quand ils font n'importe
quoi là vous c'est impossible
vous ne pouvez pas
vous n'avez aucune pour des gens comme
moi qui sont quand même très investi
dans la chose publique et tous n'avaient
aucun interlocuteur rien et quand vous
leur dites vous mais autant autant que
je parle à un mur quoi ça sert
strictement à rien tous les directeurs
de crise pratiquement 1 pratiquement
tous les directeurs de cuisson des
anesthésistes on sait pas pourquoi mais
ils sont tous sélectionnés dans
l'anesthésié
c'est comme ça le reste que c'est pour
nous endormir c'est possible mais encore
vous gardé des acteurs de crise c'est à
dire les directeurs de crise des
hôpitaux
et puis aussi les conseillers au niveau
du ministre au niveau du premier
ministre et ça et ça ça pose problème
parce que justement si vous voulez ce
sont des civils
or là on est sur la gestion de quelque
chose de masse et moi je suis convaincu
que de demander à des médecins
militaires de gérer ça on s'en sortirait
mieux il n'y a plus de commandant dans
le navire
on navigue à vue un là on ne sait pas
combien il ya de doses qui arrive demain
c'est quand même c'est si vous voulez on
a l'impression non seulement ce virus on
a l'impression de combattre un fantôme
et j'étais encore de garde la nuit
d'avant vous avez des gens qui sont très
graves qui vont pas bien qui font des
formes de co vide gravissime et vous
vous dites mais si on l'avait vacciner
si on avait vacciné cette personne
d'accord il ya deux mois on sait on sait
pas ce que c'est toutes les études qui
sont toutes concordantes
si vous êtes vacciné et que par
malchance vous attrapez le coronavirus
vous faites une forme bénigne d'accord
donc d'un coup là il ya et via vraiment
une question c'est pour ça que quand
j'aurai emploie le mot qui est énorme de
scandale d'état
c'est à dire que parce qu'on a fait
parce qu'on a une logique complètement
débile d'organisation de la vaccination
et de sélection des malades ce que je ne
supporte pas d'accord eh bien il va y
avoir des gros problème est probablement
des plaintes de gens qui diront pourquoi
vous n'avez pas vaccinés du coup je suis
tombé malade
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe puis
comme on donne sans arrêt ce qui se
passe aux etats unis
baden annonce que tous les adultes
américains fas mais seront vaccinés vous
entendez ce que fait
l'angleterre là ils ont dit on a
suffisamment vacciner on va rouvrir
on enlève des notions confinement on
trouve la société voilà c'est ça à new
york le yankee stadium
c'est la garde nationale qui vaccinent h
24 nous quand quelqu'un vient je voulais
déjà raconté je vous le confirme
vous avez des caches d'accord vous
passez devant administratif qui va de
vous demander des tas de choses hyper
importante votre mail votre numéro de
téléphone l'âge du capitaine votre
personne requérante s'il ya un problème
et c'est après il attend vous il arrive
hop vous devez tour cocher toutes un
cash ça prend cinq minutes ça ne sert
strictement à rien d'accord et après il
faut que la personne elle retourne
encore une fois pour prendre son
deuxième rendez vous voyez c'est c'est
les shadoks
c'est peut-être très anciens comme
référence mais bon mais c'est les
chasseurs est plus à ça on sait pas ce
qu'on fait et c'est et c'est là où il ya
le scandale et vous pouvez pas leur
parler
vous pouvez pas leur dire vous pouvez y
a aucun recours pour dire on est en
train de faire n'importe quoi
bilan des courses comme bien dire fort
justement alexandre on va nous dire dans
quelques temps on re confine on arrête
de nouveau la société et là on peut pas
accuser c'est pour ça que c'est un
scandale
beaucoup plus gigantesque de se dire
c'est pour ça c'est complètement
ridicule de dire faut virer untel untel
untel
ça ne changera rien c'est structurel
c'est profond cdc des castes c'est des
groupes qui gèrent le truc et qu'ils
veulent pour certains plus confiné que
vacciner je pèse mes mots
alors on a été très critique sur ce
plateau depuis le début de l'émission et
surtout vous messieurs vis-à-vis de
l'état mais il n'y at il pas aussi dans
ces retards de vaccination un rôle des
personnels soignants notamment parce que
ceux ci ne sont qu'un tiers à avoir été
vaccinés alors que là les vaccins sont
disponibles
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
leur a envoyé une lettre pour les
inciter à se vacciner même s'il n'est
pas question à ce stade d'aller plus
loin que l'incitation pour passer à une
obligation
et puis écoutez ce témoignage d'agnès
banier relâché c'est la ministre chargé
de l'industrie on sait qu'elle travaille
aussi sur ce dossier de la vaccination
notamment pour la la gestion des vaccins
est en fait elle explique que c'est pas
la première fois qu'il ya des réticences
de ce type de la part des soignants je
préfère qu'ils soient vaccinés parce
qu'il le souhaite et c'est un exercice
de pédagogie et de discussions avec les
soignants c'est un grand classique
l'hésitation des soignants à se vacciner
c'est un sujet que moi j'ai rencontré
lorsque je travaillais à l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris à plus de 15
ans sur la vaccination contre la grippe
il ya plusieurs vaccins la stasi n'est
qu'à est un vaccin qui fonctionne très
bien
il faut l'expliquer il faut donner les
derniers résultats parce que ces
résultats sont relativement récents
patrick médecins hospitaliers qu'est ce
qui se passe pourquoi est-ce qu assez
réticent alors je suis je suis vacciné
contre éclair moi je crois au vaccin il
ya des milliards d'argent par espérons
veulent pas se faire vacciner parce que
il y a alors là évidemment vous allez
dire il me sort une théorie mais je
pense qu'il ya une véritable lutte des
classes lutte des classes parce que je
les ai vus comme le début des
vaccinations ont été faites à l'hôpital
nous avons vu arriver
d'abord les grands professeurs qui se
sont tous fait symboliquement vacciner
les premiers lutte des classes après les
médecins sont venus et souvent les
médecins sont venues se faire vacciner
sans être accompagnées de leur personnel
j'ai été frappé de voir ça ou d'un coup
il arrive que tu dis mais cessons août
et infirmières des expos mais maintenant
il ya de l'astra général en menant le
monde
non non c'est maintenant c'est une
défiance c'est une défiance
les médecins sont vaccinés pourquoi moi
je vais me faire vacciner puisque on m'a
traité comme ça moi je pense est presque
une démarche syndicale
on ne passe rien dicale dans l'esprit
parce que les syndicats ont appelés à se
faire vacciner parce que les syndicats
protège donc les syndicats tout le monde
dit qu'il faut se faire vacciner c'est
c'est le premier deuxièmement c'est
souvent très compliqué parce que tout ce
qu'on a décrit précédemment
vous l'avez aussi faut prendre rendez
vous faut aller faut aller voir
vous remplissez des caches parce que on
a sacralisé ce vaccin ce vaccin syrien
d'accord moi j'ai vacciner dès sans
doute ou
une fois j'ai dépassé je pense les deux
mille personnes est vaccinée
vous affectez c'est fini ça prend une
deux secondes
mais alors pourquoi y at il des
personnels qui ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner en parlant des ambiances par
défiance parce que le système est trop
compliqué parce qu'on l'a rendu
compliqué quand on a proposé non marc
peur des effets secondaires de l'astre
enseignement pas forcément non non non
non et puis les effets secondaires de
l'astra zeneca c'est hélas des effets
secondaires qu'on a surtout les vaccins
et c'est minime on l'a monté en
chou-fleur d'accord quand on a proposé
nous d'aller vacciner les personnels
dans les services fin de non recevoir
parce que la médecine du travail ne
voulait pas parce qu'il fallait proto
colisée parce que si parce que ça parce
que l'âge du capitaine voyer voyez on a
on a complexifié
on a tous complexifie laurent alexandre
patrick pelloux défend peut-être la
corporation des personnels soignants
alors non je n'attends pas se défend pas
les avoir expliqué en tout cas j'ai
exigé une théorie c'est ce que j'ai
commencé en me disant j'ai revu mon
entendement il est contestable
critiquable sans aucun doute mais je
défends pas je pense que tout le monde
doit se faire vacciner amérique quand
même c'est c'est étonnant que
les professionnels de santé en plus à
l'hôpital donc en contact avec les
malades et des réticences à se faire
vacciner non laurent alexandre ses
critiques apps sont ce sont des
réticences qui sont les réticents
général mais vous savez quand on parle
des soignants on ne parle pas que des
docteurs en médecine et des et des
spécialistes de virologie à l'hôpital il
ya des gens qui n'ont pas de compétence
médicale et qui sont finalement comme
des citoyens normaux un brancardier
c'est pas c'est pas docteur en virologie
ou en eau en génétique et donc les gens
ont peur d'une technologie qui est qui
est nouvelle et quand vous regardez sur
les réseaux sociaux moi je suis très
active sur les réseaux sociaux on voit
énormément principalement de
brancardiers d'être soignants d'agents
hospitaliers esther de gens qui n'ont
pas une formation scientifique très
élevé d'ailleurs quand on regarde dans
les sondages la quasi totalité des
médecins veulent se faire vacciner
les infirmiers un peu moins et plus
personnel n'ont pas livré en médecine à
une défiance encore plus importante donc
il faut maintenant faire de la pédagogie
et puis on a beaucoup médiatisé les
effets secondaires de l'astra zeneca et
ce à moindre efficacité
les dernières données sont très
rassurantes et montrent que l'astra
senécal est un bon vaccin
donc il faut maintenant expliquer au
personnel que l'astra zeneca est un bon
choix et pas un second choix
alexandre je pense que c'est au delà les
personnels comprennent bien tout ça
c'est que c'est une défiance de luttes
sociales c'est à dire que par exemple
quand on a dit par exemple juste ça
quand on a dit on vaccine d'abord les
médecins de plus de 55 ans 1
voilà c'est d'abord ça il avait juste
oublié tout personnel donc déjà il ya
une défiance deuxième défiance on a
vacciné des médecins de plus de 55 ans
par exemple généticien tout à fait
honorable on les aime beaucoup mais qui
a jamais vu un malade qui est derrière
son micro scope ses ordinateurs ces
statistiques il n'ya jamais soigner un
malade eu copie par contre le
réanimateur qui a 40 ans et qui est au
pied du lit du malade et la firme hier
qui est au pied du lit du malade c'est
elle qu'il fallait vacciner douce et
pour l'heure c'est 12 une véritable
défiance nerfs et tant que vous ne ferez
pas parler des infirmiers
du vaccin vous n'y arriverez pas il faut
faire parler l'ambulancier le
brancardier l'infirmière l'aide soignant
du vaccin
il n'y a pas de raison que ça soit
toujours des docteurs qui parle du
vaccin
merci et patrick peloux de réaction pour
finir d'abord livres 92 qui nous dit oui
à un débat peloux verrons mais on va
peut-être essayé bien le bourhis qui
nous dit l'armée est habitué à gérer des
problèmes sanitaires pourquoi ne pas
l'avoir sollicité bah oui c'est ce que
disait le dr pelloux on aurait peut-être
pu faire appel à ses compétences
on va parler maintenant si vous le
voulez bien d'un d'un autre aspect de
cette pandémie qui sont les contraintes
de toutes sortes qui pèse sur les
français pas seulement le couvre-feu il
ya aussi les gestes barrière ce week-end
il faisait beau à paris un très grand
nombre de parisiens étaient descendus
sur les quais de seine un nombre trop
important aussi sans doute c'est donc
samedi après midi la préfecture de
police a décidé de faire évacuer les
quais ça n'a pas vraiment plu à la maire
de paris anne hidalgo elle l'a dit ce
matin sur france inter
d'abord il faut intervenir lorsque les
gens ne respectent pas effectivement
geste ce qui arrive aussi de consommer
des boissons sans masquer à quelques
centimètres les uns des autres mais les
scènes que j'ai vu n'était pas
exactement celle là il y avait beaucoup
de parents avec des poussettes de
personnes qui se promenaient bien sûr
avec beaucoup de monde mais on le sait
vaut mieux dehors que dedans pour éviter
les contaminations est en tous les cas
il faut faire les choses dans le respect
de toutes les autorités compris la
mienne et chez nos internautes ceux qui
nous suivent on dirait qu'il ya une
toute petite majorité 51% mais une
majorité quand même qu'ils approuvent
l'évacuation des quais de seine par la
police ce week end
est ce que vous faites partie de ces
gens qui approuvent cette décision à
laurent alexandre c'est vrai que non
l'un d'eux est dans une maison dans un
village à côté de montauban et que vous
n'êtes pas dans un petit appartement
parisien
millar minuscule vous n'êtes pas dans la
même situation les parisiens se fait un
an qu'ils ont des contraintes il ya
beaucoup de tout petits logements à
paris il n'y a pas que des grands
appartements haussmanniens dans les très
beaux quartiers pour la haute
bourgeoisie financière
il ya aussi des gens qui sont avec des
familles nombreuses dans le 19ème dans
le xviiie dans le 20e les gens en ont
marre et donc l'idée de penser qu'on va
mettre les gens sous cloche encore
pendant six mois parce qu'il ya le
waterloo vaccinale et qu'on n'arrive pas
à vacciner est une idée conne
politiquement inacceptable
donc c'est pas parce qu'il ya eu un
plantage sur le plan vaccinal qu'il faut
martyriser les gens et les empêcher
d'aller se promener sur les quais de la
seine vous connaissez ma position il va
falloir maintenant lâcher du lest on ne
peut pas continuer à tout bloquer
pendant une deuxième année
ce n'est pas possible et donc les choses
qui sont peu contaminante comme se
promener sur les quais de seine ne doit
pas être interdite parce qu'on va avoir
des explosions et les gens vont refuser
tous les gestes barrière donc
aujourd'hui il faut être raisonnable et
il faut que les pouvoirs publics
acceptent de d'ouvrir un petit peu la
cocotte-minute
sinon le printemps va être très
difficile patrick peloux les règles
avait c'était dangereux quand même ces
gens à là on prend l'argent des autres
alors non il ya plusieurs choses
1 à partir du moment où il y avait pas
ce que c'était ça le problème
il ya beaucoup qui picoler et qui est
évité le max et le masque et c'est donc
d'un coup comme on est encore avec les
mesures barrières les mesures barrières
là n'étaient pas respectées bon donc
d'un coup je comprends tout à fait
l'exercice de l'état de dire il faut
protéger la population respecte et ça ça
je suis tout bon le problème ça c'est là
où je rejoins alexandre le problème
c'est qu'on en a ras-le-bol
et qu'à partir du moment où
l'alternative qui consistait fin
décembre discours des gouvernants de
dire on vaccine et on va desserrer le
truc ne tient pas parce que j'aime
beaucoup cette expression le waterloo
vaccinale est totale ce qui fait que la
la cocotte minute est en train de
chauffer il ya un ras-le-bol général
attention à ça c'est que attention à pas
voir des émeutes et des gens qui vont
commencer à dire on en a plus rien à
[ __ ] d'accord et ça ça va poser
véritablement des problèmes il ya une
crise sociale qui est sous jacente à la
coved 19 que quasiment on a rendu
mécanique avec l' isolement des gens
l'arrêt du travail et c'est là et vous
le savez si puis un secret le nombre de
restaurants clandestins qui ne sont pas
clandestins d'ailleurs mais qui
s'appelle clandestins fleuri comme c'est
pas permis
il va falloir un moment remettre de
l'ordre
parce que sans ordre évidemment c'est
très bien d'aller dans des restaurants
clandestins la problématique c'est que
vous allez contaminer tout le monde et
comme on n'a pas une politique vaccinale
correct et bien oui ça se trouve dans
quelques semaines on va avoir à nouveau
un pic alors vous avez entendu comme moi
sur l'île de france on vient de adoum
tout déprogrammer on est saturé sur les
lits de réanimation ils n'ont pas ouvert
depuis l'année dernière ça fait c'est
lourd tout ça c'est très lourd et à
supporter quand vous êtes soignants je
vous assure qu'en vous êtes de garde etc
il est 4 heures du matin et qu'on vous
dit il n'y a plus aucun lit de
réanimation sur paris et petite couronne
qu'est ce que je fais mon malade donc
alors évidemment on pousse les murs donc
tout le monde il vous est arrivé
non on n'y est pas arrivé on met sous
tension le truc et le collègue va
prendre le malade en plus de ses autres
malades c'est pas du tout bon on en est
plus là de la qualité des soins et
surtout on est hors protocole est donc
ce qu'il y à là ce que vous voyez avec
l'évacuation des quais c'est quelque
chose c'est ça devrait servir de soupape
justement pour que les gens comprennent
qu'il faut maintenir les gestes barrière
mais ils ont tellement assez qu'en effet
il ya une saturation donc que fait le
lait le préfet est dit on n'évacue pas
ce que les gens vont skecth contaminés
bah oui ils vont se contaminer parce
qu'on les a pas vaccinés et voilà et
hélas c'est le serpent qui se mord la
queue
et moi je ne sais pas du tout comment on
va s'en sortir maintenant on va être
rigide et de penser qu'on va empêcher
les gens d'aller se promener pendant les
week-ends au printemps est totalement
illusoire si on bloque les gens dans
leurs promenades et qu'on les laisse
dans leur petit appartement pendant tout
le printemps ils viennent se révolter
mais bien c est bien sûr la révolte
d'arriver bien sûr c'est inéluctable et
si on vacciner vite les gens
accepteraient pour encore quelques
semaines de sacrifier mais comme on
vaccine à la vie à la vitesse de
l'escargot les gens vont exploser
c'est ce que nous dit oui sur twitter
ils se sont entassés dans les
appartements de 15 mètres carrés alors
qu' il pouvait aller dehors c'est d'une
bêtise sans nom
les policiers n'ont que ça à faire se
demande brigitte michel toujours sur
youtube les gens serre parce qu'en
semaine ils ne peuvent pas c'est
exactement 1 100 c est la résidence est
un non sens sanitaire d antoine sur
twitter il n'a quasiment pas de foyer
épidémique en extérieur et puis nicole
06 il faudra m'expliquer pourquoi on
nous a fermé la promenade des anglais et
le bord de mer à nice je vous propose ce
pour conclure cette émission de rendre
hommage à un homme que nous connaissions
bien au figaro puisque il était un des
administrateurs de notre groupe
olivier dassault le député et l'air de
loi c'est mort hier dans un accident
d'hélicoptère il avait 69 ans vous le
connaissiez laurent alexandre oui
c'était un type formidable
olivier dassault était un garçon
extraordinaire d'une d'une immense
gentillesse un nationaliste qui adorait
la france c'était un pilote d'avion
absolument exceptionnel et ce n'est pas
lui qui pilotait l'hélicoptère il avait
il avait un pilote avec lui il a fait
mille choses dans sa vie
il adorait l'industrie l'adoré la
science était un député formidable et il
avait une une joie de vivre une
sympathie avec les autres une empathie
c'était vraiment vraiment quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire je suis très très
triste et on perd beaucoup parce que ce
garçon était vraiment un garçon
formidable
oui il avait beaucoup de facettes sa
personnalité effectivement il adorait la
photo qu'il pratiquait presque comme un
professionnel ou comme un artiste delmas
il y avait une pâte très personnel dans
ces photos il composait de la musique
aussi
il adorait la chasse enfin il aimait il
aimait la vie vous l'avez acheté
coarraze et dès que l'on ait croisé sur
un plateau de télé une fois l'assemblée
nationale c'était quelqu'un qui en effet
moi m'a tout de suite inspirée d'une
très forte sympathie
il était pub nas dans ses idées il
comprenait tout de suite la situation et
le sens des choses et je pense que là
alors pour le coup on perd quelqu'un de
vraiment très très brillant et c'est
vraiment faim je pense à sa famille et à
ses amis dont vous êtes parce que
vraiment cesser ces affreux ce qui s'est
passé c'était une personnalité très
attachante et nous présentons nos
affectueuses condoléances à toute sa
famille sa femme ses enfants
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis bonsoir et à demain
pour une nouvelle vision de point de vue
passé
[Musique]